dollars getting stronger as it's
starting to look like the US has the
strongest economy in the world but
that's probably bad news for U.S
companies and the stock market I'm going
to explain what's happening in markets
that's pushing the value of the dollar
higher why it's happening now and is
expected to continue and why a stronger
dollar typically means tough times for
U.S stocks let's get into it after
rising to a 20-year high in September
2022 the dollar started falling and
largely kept falling until July of this
year the currency we can pretty
consistently declining along with
inflation as the stock market Rose
especially tech stocks but all that
changed in July as U.S government bond
yields started to rise and stock prices
started to fall higher government bond
yields make currencies more attractive
to Traders because they need a country's
local currency to buy its government
bonds when Traders think a country's
bond yields are going to keep Rising
they typically buy up its currency and
that pushes up the value this is an
especially lucrative strategy for
Traders who buy when a currency's value
is low and it appreciates not only are
they rewarded by the high bond yields
but the currency's higher value gives
them an additional return currencies
also tend to rise in value when a
country's economy strengthens in
comparison to other countries that's
what's happened to the U.S over the past
couple months July was when China's
economy first started showing signs of
stress weak retail sales a big slowdown
in its real estate market and Rising
unemployment have all slowed down
Chinese growth that has had a negative
impact on many Asian and European
countries because China's appetite for
their goods was helping fuel their
economies as Chinese demand pulled back
economic growth in countries that used
Euros pounds and dollars other than the
US started to weaken the U.S economy is
mostly supported by spending on services
like doctors lawyers and Uber drivers so
a Slowdown in global trade doesn't hurt
quite as much as it does in places like
Germany or Vietnam when thin Global head
of currency strategy at Brown Brothers
Harriman recently said if we look
everywhere around the world the US is
sort of like the last man standing and
the dollar is coming strong this year
with a stronger economy the Central Bank
of the U.S the Federal Reserve is
expected to hold rates higher for longer
than other central banks unfortunately
this is not typically a good thing for
the stock market when the dollar hit its
highest level since 2002 last year half
of all S P 500 companies mentioned the
strong Dollar in their earnings reports
and most of them weren't celebrating the
s p had its worst year since 2008.
certainly that wasn't all about the
strong dollar but as lots of CEOs told
us on their earnings calls it didn't
help a strong dollar makes items more
expensive in other countries so American
companies often sell fewer Goods when
the Dollar's value Rises they also make
less money because when they convert
their foreign sales back to dollars they
often wind up with less in Q2 applesauce
Revenue decline for the third quarter in
a row and said that if it weren't for
the strong dollar its Revenue would have
gone up with the dollar strengthening
again look for more and more companies
to talk about it in the upcoming
earnings season it could also lead to
more companies reporting lower earnings
in the third quarter and with the
economy starting to slow down and fears
about a recession Rising that could
really Dent the stock market